George Clooney's tequila is officially a
billion dollar company
Kim and Kanye are going for baby number
three and won America's Got Talent
singer had me crying in my living room
last night sorry guys I just have a lot
of feelings today hello friends this is
the daily Denny I'm Denny direct oh and
copy first day of summer aka the longest
day of the year now to help you get over
the long hump we're going to kick things
off today with tequila just 15 days
after having twins no not those twins
George Clooney has more exciting news to
toast the new dad and his business
partner Randy Gerber sold their Casa
miel tequila for 1 billion dollars
Clooney's company will first be paid
seven hundred million dollars with a
potential three hundred million more
over the next 10 years a source close to
the company tells us despite the New
Deal George and Randy will still run the
company and that Clooney reassured us of
that in a statement saying he and Randy
are not going anywhere there's still
very much part of Casa amigos and
they're starting with a shot tonight
maybe to his words not mine but I might
have to join you there George
alright now crazy to think costume
videos was created because the two pals
wanted to drink it for themselves and I
look at them and we know Clooney loves
his tequila look at how many times his
drink of choice has come up in the last
year alone the BT wife said I can't name
them Casas and amigos that's the one
thing I'm not allowed to do what you
want to do we're just a family business
Aquila and me and next thing you know an
even dollars flying happy hour somewhere
that is a man after my own heart
cheers to you George you got playing to
toast this year in fact while George is
busy with his new money I mean babies
Kim Kardashian and Kanye West are
looking to expand their family et has
learned Kim has hired a surrogate to
carry her third child a source tells us
this has been in the works for a bit now
and Kim herself has been very open about
wanting to be pregnant again but that a
third pregnancy would be risky for
fertility issues have been well
documented on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians
guys remember when she asked Chloe to
carry her baby so close
make yourself comfortable proposition
for you I'll catch I was thinking if you
love these kids so much well give me my
embryo to put inside of you you carry
the baby give it to me what lucky for
you quote your sis altum Utley decided
to find an anonymous surrogate through
an agency but can you imagine what that
process was like with Kanye a your
surrogate imma let you finish but can
have the best pregnancy of all time but
the process isn't cheap in addition to
paying the agency more than sixty eight
thousand dollars the surrogate will get
ten payments of forty five hundred
dollars for a total of forty five
thousand dollars and that's only if one
child is born the surrogate will get
another five grand for each child poof
alright well moving on to the
contestants on America's Got Talent
vying for that million dollar prize the
talent on season 12 so far has been no
joke and here's why it's my favorite
show the summer where else can you get a
piano playing chicken that's defying
stunts and dancing naked chef but last
night there were a couple amazing
moments that blew my mind
including a psychedelic LED lit routine
from the light balance Ukrainian dance
crews
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so ridiculous I went way even
hiding was beaming
lucky for them they even earned host
Tyra Banks first golden buzzer ever
[Applause]
I love how stoked Heidi was in that clip
now the dance crew is going straight to
the lives but it was 13 year old singer
Edie Claire who brought the audience and
used me to tears after performing
Christina Perry's arms for her dad who
is battling stage four colon cancer
[Music]
are you actually that lady right there
in the audience that was legit me in my
living room last night I can't help it
I'm a softy all right before we sign off
for the day Pretty Little Liars fans are
also shedding tears because there is one
episode left of the entire series I got
with me now our resident TV expert hello
mama
are you just called with creator Marlene
King and star Sasha Pieterse say this
morning what do you know girl what do
you know about that finale well Marlene
did spill which fan favorite characters
will be returning for this two-hour
finale as well as which characters
changed the most after the one year time
jump so lots of goodies over there
you've been on this beat for so long I
can't believe it's ending seven years of
my life exactly right alright well all
good things do need to come to an end
including today's daily Denny you guys
can catch Liane school interview with
Marlene and Sasha over on et's Facebook
page and be sure to subscribe to et's
YouTube channel for more daily denne
and of course we've got all of these
headlines and a whole lot more over at
ET online.com are you guys we'll see you
tomorrow I can gaily Danny unroll the
rundown Pacific